Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Cecilia Bernabeni
Buon pomeriggio a tutti.
Oggi tento di portarvi
dentro un racconto utopico,
su una comunità immaginaria
capace di creare una scuola
che forma gli ideatori.
Vale a dire, quelle persone
che nell'età della "conoscenza in azione"
sono capaci di generare idee
che si trasformano in avventure.
"Venture", si dice in inglese:
non solo avventure imprenditoriali,
ma avventure di varia natura.
E sono persone che fanno precedere
il ben-avere dal ben-essere,
ben-essere con se stessi
e con la comunità,
nel senso di altruismo,
di cui parlava Adam Smith
nel suo famoso saggio
"Teoria dei sentimenti morali".
Gli ideatori sostituiscono i lavoratori
della Rivoluzione Industriale del vapore,
e della Rivoluzione Industriale
della elettricità.
Oggi abbiamo una nuova rivoluzione:
la "conoscenza in azione",
che richiede persone in grado, appunto,
di muovere la conoscenza
verso delle avventure.
Il racconto ha delle premesse.
Questa è una prima premessa:
Le persone che hanno
tanta conoscenza, esperienza,
sono nel settore della moda
e vedono un cappello.
Ma i bambini dicono loro:
"Oh, bisogna essere indulgenti
con voi persone adulte!"
E perché essere indulgenti?
Perché le persone adulte,
che hanno conoscenze e esperienza,
non hanno l'occhio con la mente intuitiva.
I bambini vedono questo:
vedono un serpente boa
il quale ha ingoiato un elefante.
Seconda premessa: siamo nel 1919.
L'intellettuale Giovanni Papini
pubblica un saggio, un pamphlet,
"Chiudiamo le scuole".
E chiede che le scuole siano trasformate
in laboratori di sperimentazione,
dove insegnanti e studenti insieme
possono sollevare interrogativi
prima impensabili,
e imparare insieme dagli errori.
Nel '21 il Mahatma Gandhi,
su "Young Indian", un famoso
magazine indiano di allora,
dice che
"La scuola deve far sì che gli studenti
possono pensare con la loro testa".
E tutti e due fanno riferimento
a David Hume, che nel Settecento scriveva:
"L'apprendimento è perdente,
è chiuso nei college
e nelle celle degli studenti,
non frequenta più il mondo
in buona compagnia".
E abbiamo un'altra premessa.
Siamo nel '69, e Skinner
scrive esattamente quello che leggete:
"Se le macchine cominciano a pensare,
noi umani continueremo a pensare... come?"
Problema che oggi si pone drammaticamente,
essendo noi di fronte
all'Intelligenza Artificiale.
Pensare, pensare - come? 1969. Skinner.
E per concludere queste premesse,
negli anni '90 Tiziano Terzani,
famoso giornalista,
si reca a Tokyo, va in una scuola
elementare di Tokyo.
In questa scuola elementare,
la maestra chiede ai bambini una cosa.
E per la cosa che chiede,
c'è una risposta e una sola.
Non contano le domande,
contano le risposte;
contano le domande degli insegnanti,
non le domande degli studenti.
E qual è la cosa che chiede?
"Bambini, cosa accade alla neve
quando arriva il tempo caldo?"
I bambini rispondono in coro:
"La neve si scioglie".
"Ma non è così: la verità
è un'altra", dice un bambino.
"È che è arrivata la Primavera".
La risposta è estroversa,
la risposta è considerata sbagliata.
Ecco quindi che io penso
che da queste premesse dobbiamo arrivare
ad alcune narrazioni conclusive.
Perché non creare un ponte
tra le discipline umanistiche
e le discipline scientifiche,
e addirittura fonderle?
Perché non chiamare questo ponte "STEAM":
dall'inglese,
scienza, tecnologia, ingegneria,
matematica e arti insieme, fuse?
In italiano la parola suona bene,
suona come "STIMA",
essendo l'ingegneria con la lettera i
e non con la lettera e.
E perché non intitolare questo ponte
a Madame du Chatelet,
la grande polimath, la grande poliedrica
che aveva familiarità, contemporaneamente,
con il Latino, con il Greco
e con le scienze?
Bene: e se facciamo questo,
che cosa accade?
Accade che vediamo un nuovo panorama,
e un panorama dove ci sono
colline della conoscenza.
Ma via via che su queste colline saliamo,
che cosa vediamo?
Vediamo delle buche
di "ignoranza creativa".
Non più le vecchie buche dell'ignoranza
che ci spingeva a entrare
dentro un pozzo disciplinare
e frequentarlo fino in fondo,
entrare nei dettagli;
ma intanto, via via
che si conoscevano più dettagli,
il mondo era cambiato:
Tolomeo non è più vero,
Newton non ha più ragione.
Non ha più ragione neanche Einstein,
e perfino oggi la meccanica quantistica
presenta punti interrogativi.
Quindi dobbiamo frequentare,
come le volpi, l'ignoranza creativa.
Diventare ignoranti, non esserlo.
L'ignoranza segue
la conoscenza, non la precede.
Siamo volpi: conosciamo
tante cose piccole.
Non siamo più dei porcospini
che conoscevano una cosa, ma grande.
E poi, ancora, dobbiamo vedere
le scuole, le nuove scuole.
Le radici dell'albero
sono più importanti dei frutti:
l'albero rovesciato.
La scuola di Musk, in America,
che dice:
I bambini debbono poter apprendere
secondo le loro abilità;
la scuola multilinguista di Tokyo,
che invita i bambini
a scrivere la stessa frase
in diverse lingue,
perché in questo modo
apprendono cose nuove.
E così via, tante altre scuole
che oggi stanno nascendo
in giro per il mondo,
compresi i laboratori di sperimentazione
della mia Università di Atlanta.
Per cui io invito tutti voi
a diventare poliedrici, polimath,
e quindi a cambiare
lo stato dell'arte oggi esistente.
Abbiamo bisogno
di "pensatori di cattedrali",
pensatori che, come nel Rinascimento,
hanno cambiato il mondo.
Vi ringrazio.
(Applausi)